names Max Lombardi and I've been an
agent for ten goddamn years you want to
know what it's like let me tell you
about it
the Lombardi tails
okay so what happened is no sir would
not lie to you
I will contain myself to the purely
factual yes sir no sir the squid were
factual I have pictures no sir there was
no squid at the village anyway so we
were waiting for the skip to show up
when those gawk bastards showed up
forgive my language sir I didn't know
you were sensitive sir I'll try to be
delicate in the future anyway the GOx
they showed up they were trying to be
sneaky but we spotted them pretty quick
blacks not a good camouflage color look
I don't care if it's dark you want some
gray in there
break up the outline of course that was
before Johnson sneezed yes sir
I'll be sure to mention it to him in his
wake I'm sure as Widow we'll be
appreciative of constructive criticism
there were a few shots fired but no
casualties then more in the way of a
handshake yes sir
number wear that I do not have the
sufficient authority to initiate hostels
with a group of interest we were just
shooting at each other you know friendly
like the got commander inquired as to
the nature of our business there and
suggested that it might be best if we
left a disposition of the skip to them I
suggested that instead it might be best
if they find another skip to kill as we
had prior interest in the one expected
to soon arrive the conversation moved on
any inquiries to the health and quality
of my sexual partners I responded with
politely worded questions as to whether
or not his mother had studied in the
field of animal husbandry as he looked
like someone with farming blood the
warmth and politeness we showed each
other sir
and would melt the cockles of your heart
our palavering brains to many subjects
but are not germane to this discussion
therefore I shall not speak of them
further except to mention that my men
have a much larger vocabulary than one I
had previously credited them they truly
are a credit to the foundation was after
about five minutes in this that the
window started bleeding and we realized
that the skip was getting close with
nary a thought to our own safety we
assume positions of maximum tactility
for the skips expected entry which were
by great coincidence also mostly covered
from the Gospels then we found out where
our intelligence had [ __ ] up yet again
I'm sorry sir I didn't realize you were
an SP an intelligence operative I meant
only that despite the great efforts
which surely involved many hours of
hazardous duty behind in this fighting
paper cuts
they missed the fact that this [ __ ] a
light excuse me again sir I meant this
fascinating and no doubt valuable
specimen anyway it went pitch dark
ngoc's worth apparently fully aware of
his ability effect I mentioned only as a
curiosity what you might mention to your
erstwhile colleagues in Intel they had
night-vision goggles and seemed to feel
they were fully equipped the deal was
set skip I can only speculate based on
their screaming that they were not
briefed on its vulnerability to silver
so you know something's a universal
anyway we start firing blindly in the
direction of the noises yeah I think we
probably killed a few of them but you
didn't hear him trust me I don't think
they would have complained after we did
some cleanup and pulldown if the gods
pissed well they jumped into our off
they knew the risks same as us if it had
gone a little different
we'd have been the one scattered across
Angola and it wouldn't have been their
fault neither
excuse my French sir [ __ ] happens so who
won in the end well most of us didn't
die but we ended up terminating the skip
so you know call it a draw